ils étaient plusieurs centaines à s'être
rassemblés cet après-midi sous le balcon
de la comédie française où les
pensionnaires de cette comédie française
est certain de l'opéra de paris ont
organisé ici rap ding ning tout
simplement pour dire leur mécontentement
quant à cette réforme des retraites et
plus précisément leur mécontentement
contre à l'utilisation de l'article 49 3
de la constitution par le gouvernement
hier voilà je le disais des membres de
la culture française qui se sont réunies
nous avons rencontré un des musiciens
qui a joué cet après midi si je vous
propose de l'écouter qu'on a travaillé
pendant de très longues années
parce que c'est pour ça qu'on a passé
les concours pour entrer dans ces
maisons et que et que c'est un support
extraordinaire parce que ça peut toucher
absolument tout le monde y compris les
gens qui n'ont pas l'habitude de voir
des spectacles et on met toutes nos
capacités en avant pour essayer de
défendre nos convictions et pour essayer
de se battre contre les mesures qui sont
totalement absurdes telles qu'elles sont
présentées en tue encore plus qu'à
actuellement des prévisions elles sont
pas forcément très bonne
il y avait eu une légère accalmie dans
les grèves depuis quelques temps le 49-3
est passé on ne sait pas du tout vers où
on va mais la colère est remontée d'un
cran clairement voilà les personnes qui
étaient présentes ici se sont rapidement
éparpillés dans les rues de paris
difficile de vous dire à quel nombril et
est aujourd'hui puisque nous sommes en
plein coeur de paris et le happening que
nous avons vu tout à l'heure a attiré
bon nombre de curieux
voilà la mobilisation en tout cas ne
s'arrête pas là les syndicats ont déjà
annoncé une grande journée de
mobilisation dès demain à paris